What's really fucked up is reading about animals that that fight like right out
of the womb.
How they kill their partner.
They killed siblicide.
Yeah.
Put it.
Pull up an obligate siblicide in blue and Nazca boobies.
What are those?
What's the Nazca Boobie?
Did they live in the Nazca lines or are these,
what are these boobies?
Jamie,
help me out here.
We're hanging out in the word Boobie Boobie.
I'm still stuck.
How do you spell that?
And a z.
Ca and then boobies.
The usual way.
I'm trying to remember what I was reading about where obligate siblicide.
When one animal comes out,
the other one trust to kill the other one almost immediately has to hyenas.
Hyenas,
hyenas.
There's been,
there's been evidence of hyenas attacking their sibling while it's in the
embryonic sack and theirs when they come out,
the bigger one or the stronger one of the ones,
whatever ones healthy,
well,
almost immediately started attacking its sibling and try to kill it.
Pull up that.
If that's true,
I'm pretty sure that's true.
I want to see boobs.
I went into this,
uh,
I went to this crazy rabbit hole about hyenas recently.
What a bizarre animal that is.
So this,
the,
the false penis.
Yeah,
the false penis is just one aspect of everything.
Everything about 20% of the women die.
Okay.
Here it goes.
Obligate simple civil size.
When a sibling almost always ends up being killed.
Fugitive siblicide means the suicide fo Facul tive like it's a choice versus you
gotta do tackle tative faculty.
Facultative silver siblicide means a siblicide may or may not occur based on
environmental conditions.
Okay.
So it's sometimes will happen if there's none of resources.
So the idea is that the,
I think the breeding cycle is [inaudible].
So you either make it or you don't.
And so the danger of laying one egg and having it not work out is very,
oh this bird is fucking,
this is brother up and it has to be in front of mom and dad.
Cause you want to prove that you're worthy.
Wow.
That is insane.
Right?
So Mommy,
look at it,
beating it to death.
So this is because there's not enough food,
there's not enough food to do two.
So the first one,
the second one is a spare,
and the first one proves,
proves that he's worthy by killing his sibling,
the spare in front of the parents and says,
yeah,
you can invest in me.
I got this thing.
He uses Christ.
And what kind of bird is this?
This is probably Nazca or blue footed boobies is my guess.
That is saying that is insane.
It's hard to watch.
Well,
this is what I said about biology.
Biology cares about your feelings and the mom doesn't give a fuck about right
her.
The mom the mom wants.
Look,
the mom's excited.
This one's dying,
not fucked up.
And the mom's like,
can hey,
the older one knows what it's doing.
He's viable.
Jesus Christ.
Nature's pretty brutal,
pretty brutal.
Now it's,
it's bizarre seeing this from,
Oh God,
I don't want to see this thing slowly die.
Dude.
It's bizarre seeing it from birds,
but a,
I think it's even more ruthless the way lions,
hyenas,
hyenas killing their siblings.
That almost,
uh,
I think they were saying it's pretty universal.
That is when the first one comes out,
they tried to kill the soccer one.
You know,
this thing about lion female lions getting excited by the murder of their
children.
Whoa.
So when the new,
when the new mail takes over the pride,
his first order of business may be let's stop wasting resources on the previous,
uh,
daddy's a offspring.
Yeah.
So what happens?
Same kind of thing.
The hyena gets out and immediately starts killing its sibling.
They're fighting to the death right out of the womb.
Look at this fucking mad battle as babies like it's got,
it's still got the sack on it and they're just trying to kill each other.
This is a particularly ruthless animal.
There were,
there were saying that I'm 60% of a hyenas die as they're trying to get out of
the tube.
Wow.
What?
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
20% of women die,
whether it females rather die when they're giving birth.
But that's because of our crazy brain to body ratio.
So say,
say they have no female hyenas.
Oh,
so that giant Dick,
sorry,
I thought you were talking about high rates of human neutrality.
Female Hyena die 20% of the time when they're giving birth.
All right,
because the baby doesn't come out right.
Like they have this crazy,
you know,
they have a pho penis that is actually a vagina.
It's a,
it's an enormous,
huge and gorge cliteracy.
It's far bigger than the males.
They have to pull it back so the male can copulate with them.
But then when they give birth,
he has to come out of that Dick and they don't,
it doesn't always come out right.
So like,
yeah,
Google that because I might be wrong about the numbers,
but it's some exorbitant number of babies die and a huge number of women,
women,
I keep saying women,
female hygiene is died.
That's why I fuck up.
But they're also weird and that they're way bigger than the males.
And that's the,
because the males won't let the babies eat.
So this one of the things they think like if something is,
they're scavengers,
the males are trying to push out everything smaller.
So because of that,
the females have to get in and go fuck off.
The kid has to eat like even if it's their kid that's cool.
60% suffocate on their way out.
60% of them die on the way out.
Yeah,
and I think it's 20% of the females die during childbirth as well.
Pretty sure.
That's what I read,
which is fucking bananas.
I mean 60% though.
Imagine 60% of all kids die on the way out and then the ones that don't die,
if you got two of them,
one of them kills the other one.
It's a rough neighborhood.
Oh,
it's matriarchal society and they get birth through that fake penis.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
What is the purpose of the fake penis?
Would it take penis is a dominate the men.
They'd get on top of the bed and they go,
listen bitch.
So it's going to be,
and they've got a big old strap on.
They pegged their men at all.
Male hyenas are cooks.
They all take,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
That's where we're heading is a condition diameter,
really.
Jesus.
Ouch.
Tight suite.
Which that's,
that creates a high death rate for first time mothers.
Yeah.
High death rate doesn't say here how many,
but I think it's 20%.
The,
uh,
like the full human cliteracy yes.
I've seen one.
Have you,
uh,
not in the water.